[Applauso]
[Musica]
a te
oggi con più di 660 milioni di persone
che la leggono souyz un intelligenza
artificiale è probabilmente la poetessa
più seguita al mondo in quanto oltre ad
avere conversazioni telefoniche con
milioni di cinesi scrive poesie di
grande successo in tutta la cina
oggi tutti voi potrete scattare una
fotografia col vostro cellulare usando
una delle tantissime app basate su
intelligenza artificiale scegliere uno
stile di pittura e creare un quadro come
questo
oggi facendo un piccolo passo in più in
olanda al museo di rembrandt ad un
algoritmo di intelligenza artificiale
sono stati mostrati numerosi quadri
dall'autore poi l'algoritmo usando una
stampa 3d evoluta ma qual è la cosa meno
interessante l'algoritmo ha creato un
nuovo dipinto che i maggiori esperti al
mondo di rembrandt olandesi hanno
ammesso avrebbero scambiato per un
originale per un capolavoro dell'autore
mai visto prima cosa sia successo col
quadro non lo so oggi ovviamente la
musica che avete ascoltato prima che
iniziasse a parlare è stata pure
composta da intelligenza artificiale e
anche souyz in cina compone spesso dai
brani musicali oltre ad avere la propria
trasmissione televisiva ma come siamo
arrivati a tutto ciò quindi poesia
pittura musica
ancora oggi quando si parla di
intelligenza artificiale alcune volte si
pensa ad un computer capace di calcolare
200 milioni di mosse al secondo che ha
battuto il campione mondiale di scacchi
è vero quel computer si chiamava di blu
quel campione di scacchi si chiamava
kasparov ma quell'anno era il 1997 erano
22 anni fa era un computer preistorico
di fatto anche se si parla di
intelligenza artificiale da più di 50
anni
la crescita esponenziale di questa
tecnologia iniziata negli ultimi anni
nel 2016 in particolare un algoritmo al
fago ha battuto il campione mondiale
essere umano nel gioco del go che è un
trilione di trilioni di trilioni di
trilioni volte più complesso
computazionalmente degli scacchi a un
hub numero possibile di combinazione
sulla scacchiera del gol superiore agli
altri dell'universo quello che è stato
fatto poi è stato dare all'algoritmo le
regole del gioco l'algoritmo per tre ore
ha giocato contro se stesso e ha battuto
il campione mondiale
nello stesso anno quindi 2016
ad ottobre l'intelligenza artificiale ha
raggiunto la parità uomo macchina nel
riconoscimento visivo quindi
riconoscimento degli oggetti
fondamentale per le auto che si guidano
da sole ad esempio e poco dopo il 20
agosto 17 l'intelligenza artificiale ha
raggiunto la parità uomo macchina nella
capacità di tradurre il parlato
inscritto nel test che fanno della tilo
graf e l'anno scorso
l'intelligenza artificiale ha raggiunto
la parità uomo macchina nella capacità
degli algoritmi di rispondere a domande
su e neri che su testi che per quindi si
chiama stanford test e ora
l'intelligenza artificiale raggiunto la
parità uomo macchina nella capacità di
tradurre dal cinese alle lingue
occidentali
quindi se volete potete usare questa
tecnologia per leggere chance shine che
è l'ultimo libro di poesie scritte da
show life in cina è quindi credo sempre
interessante riflettere sul passato
perché tutto quello che vi ho detto è
vecchio del passato e se diamo uno
sguardo verso il futuro
vediamo che sta iniziando un
accelerazione sempre più rapida per cui
quello che accade oggi domani mattina e
già superato di molto e questo sta
avvenendo proprio oggi perché solo oggi
abbiamo la potenza di calcolo la
quantità di dati e degli algoritmi tali
da far nascere la vera intelligenza
artificiale
partendo dalla potenza di calcolo
all'inizio si usano le cpu sono quelle
dei computer normali poi si è visto
perché le gpu che sono quelle usate nei
videogiochi sono molto potenti per
processare gli algoritmi e oggi si usano
fpg e che sono e siamo circuiti
integrati che si configurano livello
hardware
tenete presente con la tecnologia fvg e
che è possibile oggi tradurre l'inter a
vichy pedia che sono miliardi miliardi
di parole di testo in meno di un battito
di ciglia e già oggi i transistor sono
ormai di pochi nanometri sono 500 volte
più piccoli di una molecola di sangue
esiste rosa i primi transistor della
dimensione di un atomo
qui si avvicinano al limite fisico e
infatti il prossimo passo è la fisica
quantistica si sta lavorando dai
computer quantistici che sfruttano
queste proprietà tipiche della fisica
per poter calcolare infiniti scenari
nello stesso istante
esistono già dei primi prototipi che
operano in laboratori talmente freddi
che sono il posto più freddo sul pianeta
terra
più freddo anche dello spazio profondo e
la comunità scientifica ritiene che con
questi computer si potranno processare
in minuti o forse in secondi degli
algoritmi che con i migliori computer di
oggi richiederebbero più della vita
dell'universo
tutto ciò avviene sempre più alimentato
da dati perché i dati sono all'origine
delle intelligenze artificiali come i
nostri dati c'è l'esperienza sono
all'origine della nostra vita
l'esperienza ci forma i dati formano
l'intelligenza artificiale e i dati
stanno crescendo sempre più ogni ora un
milione di nuovi dispositivi che
producono dati sono messi al mondo e
ogni anno la quantità di dati prodotti
da noi e umanità è superiore a quella
prodotta da tutta l'umanità se non anno
prima
ed è vero ogni anno cosa significa
significa che stiamo lavorando a nuove
forme di salvataggio dei dati e oggi la
tecnologia più promettente per salvare i
dati a usare il dna sintetico tantissimi
leader tecnologici mondiali inclusa la
cina sta lavorando a dna sintetico per
salvare tutte queste informazioni per
come mai perché il dna è la forma più
efficiente di salvataggio delle
informazioni nell'universo almeno
conosciuto agli esseri umani e in un
solo centimetro cubico si possono fare
informazione dei più grandi data
entra di oggi tra l'altro una volta
salvate le informazioni del dna per
sesso per migliaia di anni
quindi potenza di calcolo dati per
algoritmi sempre più profondi retino
rari algoritmo intelligenza sempre più
avanzati che stanno ovviamente
tracciando l'inizio di un percorso la
domanda alla grande domanda quindi è
quale futuro quando futuro creeremo un
qualche futuro stiamo andando e mi rendo
conto che tecnologie così potenti
possono creare preoccupazione quindi a
essere onesti
magari a qualcuno di voi essere venuto
in mente un'immagine come questa o ad
essere ancora più onesti questa è
l'immagine
ciò detto devo dire quando leggo i
quotidiani tutti i giorni mi viene
spesso veramente da riflettere sul fatto
che il pericolo più grande è che stiamo
correndo non è l'intelligenza
artificiale è il suo posto la stupidità
naturale e se voi mi chiedeste oggi in
quale futuro vivrà la mia piccola elisa
che vedete in questa fotografia
io non ho la benché minima idea perché
quello che io vi ho fatto vedere prima
su dalle traiettorie tecnologiche
stiamo andando in quella direzione
magari andremo ancora più veloci di
quello che immagino oggi ma quella
tecnologia il futuro alla fine dipende
da noi
e in questo caso davvero il modo
migliore per predire il futuro è quello
di crearlo e per moltissimi anni saremo
ancora noi esseri umani a creare questa
tecnologia spesso con successo altre
volte si spera imparando le nostre
errore per moltissimi anni saremo ancora
noi esseri umani a decidere quando usare
questa tecnologia ma ancora più
importante quando non usarla come usarla
e come distribuirne benefici perché
sempre più si può usare questa
tecnologia ad esempio per aumentare la
redditività agricola usando meno a come
lo pesticidi ma una volta che ho
prodotto più cibo usando l'intelligenza
artificiale
tocca a noi esseri umani decidere se
quel cibo rimane a poco viene istituito
a tutto il pianeta non lo decide
intelligenza artificiale e ancora per
moltissimi anni stremo noi esseri umani
a insegnare
sembra che la tecnologia che impara
impara da noi stiamo veramente andando
in un nuovo mondo dove da un passato
dove noi dovevamo imparare a te capire
la tecnologia a capire computer anche
con interfacce complicate a un nuovo
mondo dove l'intelligenza artificiale ma
che stanno imparando a capire noi quando
parliamo quando gesticoliamo e
nell'imparare a capire noi imparano
anche le cose negative che ci
caratterizzano
se oggi usasse un algoritmo intelligenza
artificiale nella maggior parte delle
aziende direi ovunque nel mondo per
decidere chi assume rocchi promuovere
l'intelligenza artificiale imparerebbe
al volo a promuovere assumere uomini
bianchi ma non è colpa dell'intelligenza
artificiale guarderebbe i dati di
quell'azienda e hanno fatto carire
risolto uomini bianchi si viene usata
questa tecnologia in alcuni contesti per
decidere per suggerire delle pene
giudiziarie si è visto che questa
tecnologia può imparare razzismo può
imparare addirittura la corruzione
serate includono la corruzione è scaduto
è però qua c'è una grande opportunità di
nuovo perché se questa tecnologia impara
da noi
noi possiamo anche entrare nella
tecnologia nell'albo ritmo e se togliamo
il fatto di ter conto dal colore della
pelle
se entriamo e decidiamo che il sesso non
deve essere una discriminante nel
promuovere assumere qualcuno sentiamo e
togliamo il fatto che in relazione
personali e quindi la corruzione
influenza una decisione
ecco che a quel punto l'algoritmo fa
davvero perché un anno subconscio sempre
più in questo percorso
stiamo andando in un mondo dove
l'intelligenza artificiale sarà come
l'elettricità ovunque oggi qualsiasi
cosa facciamo più o meno siamo
l'elettricità la stessa identica cosa
accadrà con l'intelligenza artificiale
quando lavoriamo in tutti i lavori a
casa quella domotica quando ci spostiamo
quelle auto che si guidano da sole
simili addirittura mi hanno detto
addirittura nella pubblica
amministrazione
e qua sto entrando nella fantascienza e
mi rendo quote sono un po
allo stesso modo continuando su questo
confronto con il periodo
dell'elettricità
all'inizio l'elettricità è stata usata
per fare le stesse cose che si facevano
prima
io in fabbrica aveva un motore a vapore
lo sostituisco un motore elettrico senza
cambiare nulla
un po più efficiente poi da ford e
taylor in poi si è visto
ecco l'elettricità io posso trasformare
tutta la fabbrica questo è esattamente
quello che sta avvenendo oggi con
intelligenza artificiale spesso
all'inizio viene usata per automatizzare
per sostituire poi finalmente tante
aziende ricercatori stanno usando per
creare il futuro è indubbio che fa pongo
una sfida enorme perché c'è un tema
temporali di prima e dopo
ma soprattutto tutte le competenze che
non servono più perché automatizzato
sono molto diverse dalle competenze che
servono poi quando sto costruendo il
futuro
infatti la sfida delle competenze la più
importante che avremo affrontare il
mondo del lavoro
in tutto ciò la cosa che a me piace
vedere come stiamo andando verso un
futuro di collaborazione uomo macchina
siamo partiti con gli scacchi vi
ricordate il 1997
a me piace ancora scala scatti ma
soprattutto oggi i campioni mondiali o
giocatori che giocano a scacchi usando
un algoritmo vincono contro l'algoritmo
e vincono contro gli esseri umani
oggi se io facessi vedere un esame
medico come quello che vedete qua a un
algoritmo ea un medico probabilmente
l'algoritmo è un po più efficiente in
alcuni casi oggi però si è visto in
tantissimi casi che se io quelle esame
medico lo faccio vedere a un essere
umano ea un algoritmo
il risultato è infinitamente migliore
che qualsiasi delle due cose da sola e
questo vale veramente in tutti i
contesti fra l'altro il medico in questo
caso chi usa la tecnologia avrà
tantissimo tempo in più da dedicare al
paziente
parlandoci quinellato umano e in questo
percorso di continua
collaborazione di evoluzione è sicuro
che tutto quello che si può tematizzare
ricordate lo sarà automatizzato e tutto
quello che si può tematizzare è
probabilmente molto molto più di quello
che immaginiamo oggi allo stesso tempo
proseguendo in questo percorso sarà
sempre più importante per tutti noi
concentrarci su ciò che ci rende davvero
essere umani ovvero un'empatia i
principi i nostri valori
in base ai quali costruiremo ad estremo
utilizzeremo questa tecnologia è
sicuramente l'intelligenza artificiale
ci darà un potere immenso e come diceva
benjamin parker joe pitt al di poter
peter da grande potere derivano grandi
responsabilità
il che significa per tutti noi che dal
grande potere che questa tecnologia ci
darà nell'amplificare la nostra
intelligenza
ne deriva una grandissima responsabilità
per tutti noi nell'amplificare sempre
più anche il nostro cuore grazie mille
[Applauso]